you're live chair thank
you good evening and welcome to this
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
as the crime and disorder panel tonight
on Thursday the 12th of October
2023 my name is councelor Paula spenley
and I'm the vice chairperson of this
committee but I'm sitting tonight as the
chairperson as you can see members we
are streaming this meeting live as well
as recording and by being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being
recorded during each item please put
your hand up to indicate if you wish to
speak I will then invite you at the
appropriate time could I ask members to
avoid approaching the top table as this
could create interference with the
cameras and the live stream please note
that the YouTube live stream sound
recording is dependent on the correct
use of the microphones which sometimes
we do get wrong so try and get it right
tonight therefore can I ask that when
invited to speak you remember to turn on
your microphone and to turn it off when
you
finished please reference a page or
paragraph number when referring to the
agenda papers and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible so we move on to apologies for
absence um can I have the apologies for
absence please um Sean um I've no yeah I
know I we've got counselor Simon Morgan
are there any other please oh no that's
it thank you chair thank you okay so we
move on to the minutes it is recommended
that the minutes of the meeting held on
the 20th of October 2022 so we've got
two lots of minutes here found on pages
5 to8 and of the meeting held on the 2nd
of March
2023 on pages 9 to 12 are approved as a
true and accurate record is so move do I
have a seconder now before I say this I
think we it needs to be um um if I if
I'm correct um somebody was at the last
meeting is that right
Clark at those meetings it is thank you
so who in here were at those meetings
apart from
myself CL you were okay so you're you'd
second it um okay so should we both vote
vote on it Andre it by sent fantastic
thank
you I think we move on from there okay
um
Declarations of
Interest so to disclose the existence
members um a nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other registrable
interests and
non-registration of business on the
agenda tonight having reg having regard
to paragraph nine an appendix B of the
code of conduct for members members are
reminded that they are also required to
disclose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting so any time that
you become aware of an interest do I
have any
tonight any to
declare thank you okay we move on then
public
participation which is item um five I
can advise we have not received any
submission tonight from members of the
public so that brings us happily on to
item six which is our mon District
safety partnership
update um that's p p found sorry the
report accompanying that I should say is
found on pages 13 to
34 and tonight we have Spencer Clark our
community safety manager to present the
report thank you
Spencer thank you chair I might just
have to play around this to get it to uh
where we are there you go thank you
thank you chair um members will note we
done streamlined report for this
particular meeting at the request of the
chair so I'm not planning on going
through report in any detail because
members have had an opportunity to
review it in advance and I'm not also
intending to speak anything about police
performance because we have Chief
Inspector balard to talk about police um
who's in a much better position than
what I am to talk about policing so um
what I what I thought I'd do uh at the
request of the chair is to go through
through um some of the statutory duties
we have as a partnership but what I've
done is broken broken up our five PRI
priorities into a slide for each
priority and then just to give you an
overview of what we've been doing
recently on each priority and more
importantly what's going to be happening
in the future a little bit of horizon
scanning so um for members that aren't
aware of what we do around Community
safety the community safety partnership
isn't just molden District Council is a
group of other statutory authorities so
that also includes Essex County Council
Essex police Essex fire and rescue
service probationary services and health
so they're the statutory Partners who
can be scrutinized under crime
Disorder so each year we go for the
process of what's called a a strategic
assessment so that's based on um data
which we receive on a number of from a
number of parties all of those parties
are involved earlier which then leads us
to look at what our priorities are going
to be each year uh we also base our
priorities on public perception which is
also very important because how the
public feel about crime as
well so um on to slide one so this is a
little this is the priority around
tackling crime and reducing
reoffending and uh you'll see the subset
there the focus around that is around
serious violence gangs drug trafficking
and high harm
offenses um so that's our main focus
when we talk about tackling crime and
reducing
reoffending one of the things you'll
note there is that we have a statutory
Duty now uh the serious the violence
Duty com in earlier this year uh
fortunately um our eics violence and
vulner ability unit that's what vvu
stands
for um have produced an Essex joint
strategic needs assessment so they've
produced a document for the whole of
Essex on serious
violence what we'll have is a local
input um I
received that local input today which
gives us lots of data around all of the
all of the areas in Essex broken down
into wards where the their most serious
violence is I'm pleased to tell you that
molden is the lowest in terms of
incidents per per 100,000
population um in fact compared to last
year there's been a reduction in by
12.5% which is bigger than the Essex
reduction around serious violence so at
this present moment in time we're in a
good position around that so we'll be
contributing to some more local detail
around that Jo that joint Duty and
that's one of the key things we've been
looking at um other ways in which we
tackle serious violence um we got quite
an effective CCTV system in
molden it was renewed just over three
years ago where we put Capital funding
in place um so areas such as the High
Street prominade Park and burnam
Riverside Park have had renewed C
CV um I'm going to talk about three
projects as well tonight where we've
been successful in gaining some funding
from the police Commissioners safer
streets fund these three projects have
broken down to a to a total value of
$189,000 just to give you a idea of how
successful that is uh annual Grant from
the police Commissioners just over
£14,000 a year so when you see that that
sum of money has been achieved it's
really good and we've also got matched
funding for those projects so just to
talk about um I'll talk about one of
them now which is the Burnham Town CCTV
system so I've been working with Burnham
Town Council for a couple of years ago
where we've been scoping the idea for
CCTV and uh fortunately in this Current
financial year Burnham Town Council have
an allocation of 25,00 000 for a CCTV
system so it's really good cuz it
already priced up a scheme we had a
scheme in place ready to go so when we
bid for the funding that
£25,000 uh could ver virtually doubled
to another £50,000 because we needed 50%
matched funding so that will make the
scheme much better it also extend the
scheme to the ini initially scam uh
scheme plan scheme which will cover
burnam rail station as well now which is
one of our hot spots in the town so
we'll be increasing that uh the plans
are to complete that in this Current
financial year so that's uh uh we've
already got that in place to start
moving on that once we get the funding
agreement which is expected this
month um other sort of works we do is
around the j9 domestic abuse awareness
uh where um we get safer places and uh
j9 to come in and talk to people about
domestic abuse awareness that's really
important that we do that with uh not
just schools but also any interested
groups counselors Parish counselors so
if anyone's interested in that that's
funded for another year now by the
police commissioner and they're done
online once a month so if any members
are interested in doing the j9 domestic
abuse awareness but again um domestic
abuse has been going in the right
direction for the last last couple of
years now we had a peak around the
pandemic which was you know because we
had perpetrators and victims living at
home but now that's going in the right
direction which is really good um also
what we do is we do quite a bit of work
with Probation Services unpaid work
probably remember it's Community payback
what it used to be called so uh working
with Probation Services and they're
really really Keen to extend that now in
all areas of uh I and the district and I
know we we we do quite a lot of work
around there green spaces in creme
crematorium with uh um the probation
service and the other important thing is
uh what we need to uh which which we
need to get better on although it's
again in the going in the right
direction is effective engagement with
communities but again I'm not going to
say too much about that because I know
Mr Ballard uh picks up on some of the
work we've been do good work we've been
doing with the police
recently so our second priority for the
partnership is driving down antisocial
behavior in public places with the main
focus of that being on youth nuisance
and improving partnership
visibility many members of the
partnership um do a lot of work around
that so we uh will uh Patrol hotspots uh
do community engagement and more
importantly listen to the concerns of
the public to know what's going on and
where uh our community engagement team
play a key role in providing reassurance
and intelligence and have a very good
relationship with the young people of
molden District which again it's not all
it's not all bad stuff being able to
talk to young people and point them in
the right direction is also a good way
forward we also have to effectively case
management our case manage our
complaints and use our powers where
appropriate you'll see the powers are
changed uh about 10 years ago the the
antisocial Behavior crime and policing
act came in it made it a lots more
flexible as to how we can deal with
issues um minor issues we deal by means
of a warning a community protection
warning which can escalate to a
community protection notice a written
notice and can ultimately end up with a
Criminal Behavior order um you probably
remember the old asbos something similar
to that a criminal Behavior order and uh
we've been successful in in putting
those into place other parts of the uh
that legislation we can use are things
like closure Powers so say for example
if we have a house uh cooed by a drug
dealer we got the powers to close that
property for three months so that only
the person who lives there can come out
of that
property restorative justice and
mediation
we've got a couple complex cases in
molden we're looking at at the moment
whereby sometimes neighbors don't just
get on and you know it's not always a
criminal meets a criminal threshold for
we dealing with it so uh we quite often
uh in such cases uh speak to the police
commissioner's office who have a restor
of justice and mediation team there with
star of justice is a really good way of
trying to explore ways of resolving
problems s and one of the cases we're
dealing is mediation between three
particular families so I don't know if
it will work but it's the best way of
trying it uh so and
uh another important thing we need to do
you'll see we've got this focus on youth
nuisance we actually need to give our
young people something meaningful to do
so uh provision of diversionary
activities such as the Monday night just
play we do over at the plume um cvfs
have an excellent program called The
Power of gaming which uh I believe has
extended out to southminster now so uh
uh that's been running in molden for
about 18 months now but now got funding
to extend that and uh the skate ramps uh
which brings me on to another area of
the police commissioner funding so the
skate ramps in uh moldon are beginning
to look a bit sorry um and uh there's
106 funding in there for for the next
financial year to deliver a skate park
project there um we've been successful
in getting some funding to around
Community safety to make that a lot
better when it's complete so some of the
areas we're going to be looking at are
putting additional CCTV in putting
Lighting in for the skateboard park
which is something we done last year in
chelsford so that people can use the
skate park throughout the year which is
important and
these sort of things are what young
people want people like liting lighting
people like cameras they like to feel
safe where they're doing these types of
projects but the other more interesting
piece of work we're work doing is a
river charity called make space for
girls so a lot of the things you'll see
in our green
spaces um are designed default male not
not by you know so things like like
skate parks muga pitches Urban
basketball courts they're not designed
for males and males only but if you look
into the detail around it 85% of those
users are male so by working with the
charity mag space for girls we're going
to be doing
consultation with 13 to 18 year old
teenage girls to see what they want from
the green
spaces um so that's going to be a really
important bit of consult
which hopefully will inform planning
policy going forward because uh you know
because it's not right is it that you
know it's trying to make it more
inclusive so uh when we look at the
skate
ramps we shouldn't just design a skate
ramp for skaters we should also design a
what we call a transition skate ramp or
skate ramp for Learners so those who are
less confident and want to learn how to
do it um so that's a that's that's
included in this a part of the
consultation so really really pleased
and also uh working with some Street
artists to do some artw work around the
area as
well so um on to our third priority and
that's around identifying and supporting
vulnerable
people so the focus on this particular
area is around domestic abuse which I
highlighted
earlier B which is violence against
women and
girls social
isolation Suicide Prevention poor mental
health and hate crime so it's again we
do quite a lot of work across all of
these areas um our main focus is around
education and events so uh we've been
into the schools uh commissioned safer
places to do talks on healthy
relationships which is really important
um there's been some uh the way lot lots
of uh press around people like social
media influences like Andrew Tate and
the impacts that's having on young males
uh and so it's important we get in there
and speak to just not just girls but
also young boys about their behavior and
you know so we're that's important we do
that crucial crew is uh something we
deliver to year six students so that's a
transition year before they go to
secondary education uh for the third
year running we commissioned uh tick
boox Productions who are a drama company
who do a drama on uh called liines based
on county lines and exploitation and
knife crime and uh once they've done the
45 minute drama uh the young people have
an hour and a half to speak to the
actors about what could be done
differently so they they can be a police
officer or parent and they just explore
ways of uh how they can be Health
better I put about safe well and secure
on there and the importance around that
so safe well and secure is a project
which Essex fire and rescue uh uh lead
on um it was only uh I think this time
last year when I presented to the
committee I explained that um we'd had
three tragic deaths in the space of 18
months in molden through uh Fires at
home and every one of those ones which
we
investigated the victim was very similar
they were over 60 they were socially
isolated and had uh cluttering hoarding
tendencies um probably not known to
services but Mo almost certainly known
to their community so uh we really
wanted to see what we could do better to
try and reduce the risk of Home Fires um
the the added impact of the cost of
living crisis and the energy crisis um
particularly in places like the DJI piny
you might have people who are what we
call Asset rich with their own home but
cash poor just living on a single
pension so you know so they could end up
sort of burning things like pallets
rather than actual fires so we we we
really needed to look at look at that so
we worked with the fire service and uh
they crunched all of their data to see
what the best area would be to tackle um
area really looked at was probably
UH 60 year olds whose kids have left
home um so this is the profile we looked
at which was probably the sort of best
sort of area to tackle um so we knocked
on a hunt well
1,499 doors over 3 days I wish it had
been 1500 so I wouldn't have to written
that but that's how many we did knock on
um and when I say we um Le Les who is
our Tri service pilot officer for the
fire service uh arranged it all and I
think he was a bit Gob smacked when a
whole Army of officers from the council
and voluntary Services went there to
help him so that that's what man well we
we we got 512 contacts from doing that
which uh related to 95 referrals and
117 home fire checks so when I say the
referrals it might not necessarily be a
fire related referral it might be a
referral to a social landlord for a
handrail or something like that so
really good piece of work and a really
good way of targeting an area which
through data we think we know is at risk
um for the March meeting next year um
I've been promis that somebody from the
fire service will come and present to us
um which will be really good
unfortunately the
uh station Commander was Ann on annual
leave and couldn't make tonight but I've
been given the promise that somebody
will be along to the next one um another
couple of areas there
um around prevent and
protect um the prevent Duty um is around
preventing violent extremism um I
actually I'm the chair of the Essex
prevent group so uh as you can imagine
I've been quite busy since last weekend
um so uh prevent sort of turned itself
on its head in the last three or four
years so uh when we were originally
looking at prevent for our area we were
looking at the threat of Islamic
terrorism um I'm not saying that's not a
threat anymore but the biggest threat in
essic is
um the extreme far right and More in
particular if you you wanted to focus uh
where you put your
attention it was only near meeting a few
hours ago with higher education
establishments would
be 14 to 18 year old boys are most at
risk to radicalization at the moment so
I always say to people the most
dangerous place for our children at the
moment is their own in their own bedroom
so the number of young people during the
pandemic particularly young boys who got
bored who are accessing extreme far
right material and we always say it will
never happen here when you see the
headlines tomorrow of a 19yearold boy
from great notley was arrested on
terrorism charges
today that's not far up the road from us
and you know and bran Tre bran Tre
districts not very dissimilar to molding
in many ways shapes or forms so there's
a lot of work going on around that and
we're trying to get some funding from
the home office to do some wider
training particularly in higher higher
education establishments because that's
where our biggest risk
is um our Council Duty under prevent um
is really around um our it structure and
uh not
allowing hate speeches in Council
buildings and since we don't tend to
have any it's not a big risk to us but
the new Duty comes in on the 31st of
December so I'm working alongside
offices to make sure we meet all of that
criteria the other one is protect Duty I
don't know when this is coming in it
should should get Royal Ascent this
Autumn uh the pro protect Dy has been
called Martin's law that's about um
recall the tragic uh bombing in
Manchester and the inquest around that
uh that will bring in some uh duties for
councils around publicly accessible
spaces publicly accessible Loc locations
and it will mean that some staff will
have to have competency training around
uh risk and terrorism as a result of
that I should imagine that will actually
become a duty early in the New Year if
it receives Ro Ascent in
Autumn excuse me one
second the other area I was going to
focus on I know I think it was actually
um was it your good South uh bo about
women's safety um so women's safety uh
um the third part of the bid to the
police fire and crime commission's
officer is to is uh doing a project
around women's safety for molden
district um so we've done a very
successful one in Chan which we launched
about this time last year so we're going
to look to replicate that project for
molden it will include a video filmed in
molden so for the social media
campaign and uh using a consultant to do
training with businesses and uh
Professionals in molden District so
that's something we'll get going uh
probably in the springtime for molden
but we've got the funding in place to
that so they're the three big projects
we're getting funded by that again so
much more data around women's safety we
have map a mapping tool called op op
manura where we've uh Essex has
collaborated with notum Trent unit
University where we can overlay maps
about women's safety and uh I've already
spoken about Mak space for girls and
trying to incl increase
inclusivity uh for a lot of the projects
that we
do fourth priority is around rural crime
and this was around increasing the
confidence in reporting rural crime
because remember a couple years ago we
had lots of rural crime but it wasn't
necessarily been reported and if we
don't know about it we can't deal with
it so uh that's I think that's gone a CH
change direction now uh this year uh the
Essex Royal crime strategy uh was uh not
relaunched it was the first strategy
come to its end and uh this was renewed
uh and it impacts on lots of areas of
roal crime a agricultural theft you know
I don't know much a tractor costs but
it's probably 1002 200,000 so it might
be small in terms of numbers but in
terms of value and the impact it can
have on the farm trade absolutely
massive um large fly tipping things
Heritage crime and unauthorized
encampment so all all big things which
happen in rural areas where we've been
trying to impact again our community
engagement team do loads of work around
that they do the investigation of
environmental crime through op fume and
things like doing checking waste
carriers licenses that's really
impactive because if people a lot of the
criminality on the on particularly on
the denji Peninsula being able to check
licenses and things and making sure that
what they're doing is good and proper is
really important I did mention the tri
Service Officer role uh Les Les Davis
he's employed by the police fire and
ambulance service he's absolutely
fantastic there's another Les in nutford
now so they like Les so much they've
extended a rooll to atford to another
Roar area and he just gets into all of
the raw areas if we're doing a patrol
anywhere Les will be there but it's the
important stuff is doing the advice and
things like that and he's a trained Medi
as well which is also
important so again The Joint work in the
travels with ESS Essex uh ryal re
engagement team sorry my voice is going
and
uh the environment agency and again that
bottom one I'm not going to say too much
about that cuz I think uh Chief
Inspector might pick up on hair Corson
as part of his present
ation finally on the our final pres uh
priority for molden is uh promoting road
safety and challenging their responsible
driving again the community safety team
are CS accredited the community safety
accreditation scheme of Essex police uh
which enables them to do enforcement
above and beyond what the police do um
we've got 40 five locations across 18
parishes in
molden um you can see the true cam
catches for the last year was
3,55 We bought them a new unit which we
saw in the office earlier so uh the old
unit was getting a bit true the old true
cam was about six years old so uh We've
bought a new lightweight laser cam unit
now which uploads the data instantly so
not only does it streamline it for the
staff so they don't have to do all the
paperwork now um that's up and running
now so we'll be able to hopefully do do
more of that we also rely very much on
community speedwatch The Volunteers in
the community and the South fesic roads
partnership attend most of the community
engagement events we do so they'll have
their cars along there to uh talk about
um road safety and push that Vision zero
message and again education uh by sep
but I'm not sep so south essics parking
partnership I'm not going to say
anything about that because Mr binder is
going to talk about that as part of his
presentation um the roads partnership
and the Education team at the fire
service who go into the schools and I've
got a list of all the schools theyve
been to in molden uh it's not just
around Road Safety they do one on hate
crime they do one on the great far of
London lots of different subjects so
that is uh my new streamline
presentation chair um thank you open to
any questions well thank you very much
for that Mr Clark and I think it did
help really explain um um some of the
things that are going on so before I
move to comment and debate I've got I've
got the recommendation on page 13 of the
report which is simply that members
review and comment on the current
progress of the initiatives undertaken
by the partnership to dat so do I have a
second for that quickly before we start
the debate fantastic thank you Council
Neil so um following that I will open
the floor to
questions comments oh councilor moley um
yes thank you for that um I remember
from the last meeting you're saying
about the pandemic would you say
the domestic violence is down to a level
just before the pandemic would you say
or is it still going
down I don't have the actual figures in
front of me but it's a steady downward
Trend and what's really important is
high-risk offenses have significantly
gone down and it was the high-risk
offenses which were hurting us during
the pandemic uh as I explained when
you've got uh victims and perpetrators
living in the same home that had a
really big impact so the high risk of
really really um and and medium risk I
believe as well have also gone down so
uh it it's it's a it's a really good
Trend um there's been lots of work going
on around domestic abuse and it's
particularly in the last couple years
has sort of turned it
on not just protecting the victim but
also challenging the perpetrator and
making sure that the perpetrator getting
that help and advice as well I don't
know if you've seen the reflect program
which was uh I think it was originally
released about a year ago actually got
an award for the impacts it's made on
challenging people's behavior because it
is very much about Behavior change and
you can guarantee that most perpetrators
to domestic abuse haven't just abused
one
person it's probably a long list of many
people so it's important that we change
the perpetrators ra as well as focusing
on the victims as
well come back yeah I think also the
lighting would be a massive I I know
with the economic and and environmental
impact but I I think safety over rules
that really if you can you know with the
nighting but also going on to you were
saying about fly tipping the snag is now
they've they've brought these new rules
out with furniture and things like that
mattresses um um wood also shortly
coming into hazardous waste so I think
you're going to have be a lot more
Vigilant with um in
particular um waste carriers license and
things like that but I think you're
you're going to see an increase in fly
tipping you know you just it's just
going to be natural with especially
sofas because they are expected to get
rid of now thank you thank you I think I
think that's very important a very good
comment the more work we can do around
that the better the more way we can use
it technology like automatic number
plate recognition we've got the denji
Peninsula well covered by that uh but
doing that that joint work with uh other
agencies is also really important so
even things like the true cam
enforcement somebody being present on
the roads you know make creating a
hostile environment really for fly
tippers really is
important any other other questions
councelor
Stevens thank you yes you talked about
um young engaging young people and I
think you said you were rolling out
something into southminster what what's
your program for Rolling that out any
further than um I presume that it's in
molden Burnham haybridge and now
southminster so I'd be interested in
what else is to come please thank you so
so that particular project is run by the
CVS uh voluntary service and uh is
funded uh by Essex violence and
vulnerability unit um so it's only
really started off in molden for about
18 months um the next place they were
going to take it to which I believe has
started in South Miner um we'll we'll
look at hotspots across the district and
give consideration to where it can be
extended to but again that's subject to
funding and subject to the the people
and the volunteers being able to be used
by the CVS to do that but any particular
areas we're we're pushing as much as we
can in all areas across uh the district
using the youth Service uh I know one
area is it Toby I believe you're from
was trying to get that um youth club
back up and running um it's again it's
like it's one of these youth one of
these things we're struggling so much
with post pandemic all of those really
good people who used to
volunteer um aren't volunteering anymore
uh we we even with things like Street
pasts uh we're really suffering with
volunteers and SOS bids so I think it's
something we just need to do a bit more
work on because it we need to make sure
that all of the outling districts have
youth diversionary projects not just
molden district and Burnham so so it's
something which we'll certainly consider
and expand if there's resources
available to do so brilliant so any any
other questions members well I I've got
some questions so I wanted to make sure
that members have spoken first okay so
my first question Mr Clark relates to
the use of CCTV in Moren and Burnham and
the projects that you've got there which
sound great but um I wondered you know
talking about southminster and hybridge
and other potential hotspots are there
any plans to to increase CCTV coverage
there anything that's going
on so um in terms of uh plans for
extension none at present but um we have
been uh trialing new
technology um in rural locations um one
of them at a Road in South hanningfield
which the Chief Inspector will be very
familiar with
where we have a street racing problem um
and it's worked relatively effectively
and um low cost in comparison to uh
other projects which we've used the the
main cost of trying to
integrate cameras into a central video
management system is really expensive
but using the mobile phone data okay and
having connectivity like that on a
different system um it's it's something
which we can look at for hotspots I
think so it's something if there was if
there was support for projects we'd
certainly be happy to have a discussion
to look at hotspots around the district
brilliant that's that's really worth
knowing I think in going back to
parishes because a lot of our members
are parish councilors as well um another
thing that I'd I'd quickly like to ask
is around you mentioned um operation
manura and the mapping tool for women's
safety um this is a meeting for the
whole District so I don't want to start
going on about hybridge because I can be
guilty of that sometimes but we all draw
we all draw the examples we know don't
we so for example we've got um a path
there where we've not had a light and
multiple women have approached
counselors and we've tried to sort it
out and essics are are saying that you
know they need the police to declare it
dangerous um it's a little walk through
that they're having trouble replacing
the light for technical problems but
again in terms of using the mapping tool
um that's an area that I guess we'd want
reported so who can access that mapping
tool and how does how would it
work so the manuring mapping tool is
professionals only okay but um
only about five weeks ago um the County
Council released another mapping tool
for the public um I I will send the link
to that to the committee clerk so that
members can look have a look at that
good whereby you can go on to a map of
anywhere in Essex stick a DOT on the map
and if you feel unsafe tell them why you
feel unsafe so I would urge you to put a
dot on the map in hybridge we'll all go
around if you go on to the map at the
moment I can assure you that there's
about 20 reports around chord bus
station yeah uh which is probably the
most reported place in Essex at the
moment um in terms of women's safety
um so if it's something like bad
lighting antisocial Behavior or
overgrown bushes as we spoke earlier you
know lots of things can impact on
people's safety uh things like improving
natural surveillance is a really
important thing you know being able to
see around the corner or having a corner
lit so that you can see around it so
I'll I'll put that in the link for the
minutes if that's okay chair fantastic
that would be great and I've got just
two very quick questions one is around
speaked speed watch and whether we how
many speed watch um groups we have
across the district now and whether or
not you could possibly get us a link
through the clock for our various
communities for Speed watch because I
think that's a really strong thing I can
certainly do that I don't know how many
there are but the lady who deals with it
that the fire service I think she's
employed by um will be able to send out
the information for members that would
be good and very quickly lesz Davis our
wonderful triy Services officer I
remember that he was a pilot well not
literally a pilot but I
mean he it was it was a pilot project um
so has that been um that is he permanent
now will that be reviewed or can we be
satisfied that we're going to keep him I
I think I think on Monday night Mr Hurst
the police commissioner referred to as
the trial service officer and there's no
mention of the word pilot in there so um
I I'm making the assumption that on the
basis that they've now extended the role
to atford that it's no longer a pilot
and they'll continue to fund fund that
although it's always difficult when
roles are funded by three different
organizations like police fire and
ambulance service but I think uh they'd
be on a hide into nothing if they took
the roll away brilliant thank you okay
so if there are no more questions I'm
just going to see if I can agree the
recommendation by S that we've all noted
that report
fantastic okay so we're going to move on
now to our next item which is a police
performance update and it's a verbal
report so agenda item
seven um and it's going to be delivered
by Chief Inspector Paul ballad who I'm
delighted to welcome back to the chamber
this evening thank you um please present
the report um B thank you thank you
chair um one second let me just um get
the it up in a viewable fashion okay
lovely so good evening everybody good
evening share um my name's Chief
Inspector Paul balard um and this will
be the the presentation from ess6 police
from a m District perspective um for
this committee so just a bit of an
overview let me see if that's going to
work yes so um your district has a
24-hour response policing team based
within the building um and addition to
that you have um a more than town team
which are also based here at the council
offices um since October
2022 and also the community um policing
team that's based out of the chelsford
safety Hub in chelsford city council
that have responsibilities both within
the chelsford district and also the MN
District um the community policing team
inclusive of the MN town team work
alongside both um the local community
safety partnership and other partners um
to work towards those Community safety
Partnerships priorities but similarly
they also work towards the priorities
set by our chief conable Mr Harrington
um which is on the next slide so this is
the Essex police force plan on a page um
it looks a little bit busy but I promise
you it really is quite straightforward
um so our main four um priorities will
always be our victims making sure that
we do the best um for our victims as we
possibly can um to tackle violence um to
deal with and support and then tackle
vulnerability in relation to them being
the victims of crime and also supporting
and preventing them being the victims of
crime and then being visible in the
community um you'll see in the middle
there we've got our policing priorities
in regards to specific offenses um but
in general terms the the main effort is
around the outside and that we'll always
look to try and prevent crime and
antisocial behavior when we're not able
to prevent it we'll make sure that we
respond as we should and appropriately
and once we've responded we'll make sure
that we investigate it um as we should
um and then how we will work it's I
appreciate that's probably quite small
so I do apologize but um in general
terms it outlays how we are going to
achieve those things and do them as we
should do um on the next slide we have
the the police fire and crime
Commissioners 12 policing priorities in
relation to Crime um you'll see there's
a significant amount of crossover um
with the force plan which is as it
should be um some of those are specific
to to to more rural crime areas which is
wholly appropriate along with um safer
roads and also um increasing
collaboration with other forces other
partners and other Emergency
Services uh now we get into the M than
specific stuff um so in the last 12
months up to the uh the rolling 12
months apologies up to the end of last
month um crime in the M district is down
14.4% that's all crime um antisocial
behavior is down
49.4% and to put some context on that um
that is
242 less reports of antisocial behavior
in the last 12 months compared to the 12
months before um residential burglary is
down
11.9% uh and you'll see there from the
uh less offenses when compared to the
year before that there a relatively low
number of residential burglaries in the
M District thankfully anyway um but that
is against a an increase across the
force of an average of 5.1% so and
particular outlier in the molden
district um other area of other areas of
notes for the MRI District um violence
with injury is down by
7.4% uh robbery is down by 20% however
um theft offenses are up by
41.8% with the majority of those being
in relation to shoplifting and um what
we classify as other theft which um I
can go into a bit more detail if there
are any questions on that afterwards
because it's quite a specific
terminology we're
using um so just a bit of an overview
around this so every quarter Essex
police um I say we employ them every
quarter we they're they're constantly
employed to do this but we get results
every quarter um a private independent
company who is not just um engaged with
byic police but other forces around the
country as well to conduct a public
perception survey with the public of
each district um it's a representative
sample of individuals are contacted
within um each policing District in
Essex and they are asked a number of
questions and their responses are
recorded and then um an anonymized and
then put back to the force in relation
to a quarterly report so you'll see
there um there it's quite a bit of data
there on and hopefully it's not too
small I think on the big screen but
you'll see that the perception data for
Moren um is a little bit up and down
what I would say in relation to this is
that um you'll notice that some of the
areas where these are slightly higher is
is during the covid period um and that
not something that was unique to Essex
that was something that was uh
nationally seen across similar surveys
um in relation to public perception
around policing and the confidence in
policing did see a large increase during
the covid affected times um which you've
then seen is is what we would address as
a sort of not a return to normality but
certainly a return to a degree of what
we had before covid but similarly we are
still in a better position across a
number of different measures uh in
relation to those um just to provide a
little bit of additional context to this
slide and the next slide um for the
molden district specific specifically um
we are either above the force average
the ess6 force average or or at the
force average for every single one of
these um perception survey so we are not
an outlier um from a negative
perspective in any of these survey
questions and similarly Essex police as
a whole is um above the um General
average for other forces of a similar
make size and um demographic so we are
in a good position not just in Essex but
also in the modern districts around our
uh public per ception however of course
we're always looking to
improve um I'll leave that slide there a
little bit just so you can see the type
of questions that we've asked and I
appreciate I I probably could have
clicked through that halfway through my
explanation but um you'll see there but
I can always come back to these and I'm
I'm more than happy to give further
information on any of these at the end
if any uh members have
questions um so what how are we doing it
what are we doing in Moren so um in M
we've seen an uplift of officers
following the um the pup uplift um
that's seen nationally the extra 20,000
police officers to policing from the uh
from the government um that uplift has
ended as of ail March the 31st this year
um so we have had our popup lift which
has for the molden district has
predominantly resulted in the M Town
team starting uh here in October last
year um but it also has mean meant a
maintaining of the uh the 24-hour
response capability out of the the
council offices um in addition to that
um we are risk assessing every single
one of our antisocial Behavior incidents
from a risk and um threat harm risk
factors um to ensure that we are
providing the appropriate response um
and we are also ensuring that we are
placing our vehicles with the
appropriate Badges and in the
appropriate areas to to provide
confidence within rural policing we've
already mentioned our Tri Service
Officer so I won't talk about him
anymore um because um he does a
fantastic job and we all know that um we
have a community safety engagement
officer for Moren which just to give you
a bit of an overview um that's an
officer whose um role is designed to
ensure that we are engaging with the
community in a way that we should be
we're listening to the community and we
are telling the community what we're
doing so that we're not just assuming
that we know what the issues are
obviously we we like to think we know
what the issues are and we always try
and and predict what the issues are but
similarly um and if not more importantly
listening to the community and
understanding what the community's
issues are is where we want to be and
certainly what we look to do um I've
already mentioned the dedicated town
team for the for mm which are doing some
fantastic work and then we've got
closely Aon with our our partners and
our neighborhood watch teams um within
the district as well which really
provide us with some good support um we
have regular operations in and around
mden in regards to antisocial vehicle
antisocial vehicle use and speeding um
and additionally we've got um some
really good links in with local
community engagement with with clubs
Scout um Scouts and and various
different um schools so that's very
positive as well um one thing I I I put
in here um or I asked to be put in here
and it isn't for any other reason than
as you'll probably you might have
remembered from the the slide that one
thing that we are quite high for in
malen as per the public perception
survey was the importance that the
community felt we had around foot
patrols and visible foot patrols I'm
glad to see that unlike last time I was
here there actually all of my officers
have got hats on um because one of them
didn't in the last presentation that I
gave yes so yeah glad they listen to the
feedback um so um yeah no and as I say
this is a really really useful tactic
it's both a useful tactic from a
policing perspective but also from a
public perception and an engagement
point of view so that's something that's
really clear and I make clear so whilst
you know I have to be you know
operationally sound with how I utilize
my 24-hour Response Team um my you know
the warden town team have the capability
and certainly the uh the drive to be out
on foot talking to the community and
being visible in the community so we
always look to do that as much as we are
able um and they certainly do it um an
awful lot um those five photos aren't
respective of a whole Year's worth of
work I can very much assure you of that
um Community engagement um so we do an
awful lot of this um and that's only a
very very quick snapshot of some of the
pictures that they've taken at various
events now the community engagement
takes on a number of different forms it
can be community engagement specific to
a particular demographic or area um or
it can be Community engagement at large
public events or similarly Community
engagement that we have our self
initiated at various different parts of
the um the district because we've been
informed there's an issue there so
there's it's both proactive and reactive
and we obviously the OB obiously
obviously offer the opportunity for um
you know members of the public to um
voice their concerns talk to us about
the issues that are affecting them and
provide us with information that's
that's really vital in how we we you
know we deal with antisocial behavior
and crime um just to give you a bit of
an update it's a bit of a police only
type Endeavor at the moment but um we've
also to to improve how Essex police um
record an audit and and make sure that
we are in the right places um we are all
now um recording on a an app which
sounds um very Swanky and it is actually
very very good because it provides us
with a good bit of mapping um all the
engagement that we're doing via QR code
so any offices that we are do are doing
their Community engagement um we can
strategically View and see exactly how
many we've done every month and where
we're doing them and the feedback that
we're doing them and that's all getting
placed into a centralized team that then
provides certain strategic reports to
officers to be able to make sure that
we're doing um a better job and it's not
as um necessarily
um randomized as as it previously been
so that's something that's very positive
and has been in for about four months
now so that's very good um also means
that chair I think next time I make a
mental note and a visible note after I
finish talking I might be able to
provide you some information some
physical information around engagement
at the next Comm the next meeting
because we'll have that app to do that
where I couldn't
before um a little bit more there on our
our community engagement and some of the
things that we're doing um it was very
abundant to um all within polic in that
that due to certain challenges
financially and also then subsequently
through covid um we had to have a a
minimum footprint within local schools
which was something that we we didn't
really like the position to be in and we
were looking to rebuild so um that's
something that's really important to my
my team and and something they always
look to take the opportunity to do in
fact we we probably get more requests
than we can service on most most months
to be fair particularly in the summer um
which you can probably appreciate but um
we always try to spread out our
engagement and never go to um the same
school too often so we spread it out in
regards to you know the coverage that we
have because you know you appreciate how
many schools and Nur we have in the
district um but that's something that's
very key to to for us for the next
generation and ensuring that we um you
know we engage with our younger
Community as well as as all others um
enforcement wise so it's not just about
Community engagement obviously we're
here to lock up bad people when they do
bad things so um the community policing
team particularly but also the response
team are very very proactive around this
type of thing um and you know we've
looked and and given an example um I
appreciate you probably can't see
exactly on there but um just just for
your awareness really the the molden
town team themselves just that that
small team of officers on their own have
arrested 20 people involved in um county
lines and um organized criminal drug
activity um which has resulted in um
seven convictions totaling a total of
eight years where they've seized over
£20,000 in cash and and a quantity of
drugs as well as Vehicles as well um
they are regularly doing warrants
addresses um and taking out enforcement
action so um they are really really been
proactive in relation to that and and I
would also tip my hat to to you know
Spencer and the team here as well
because um they work hand in glove with
us in regards to this um appreciate that
some of the enforcement stuff is police
L as it should be but a lot of the
information and a lot of the background
work he done in collaboration with our
partners at the council so that's that's
always really really key to us um speed
checks so something that's very
important to the community in in mden
and the District of Moren sorry um and
the surrounding areas and understandably
so given that you know some of the
concerns around Road Safety so my team
in conjunction with um as um Spencer is
very um you know very eloquently already
verbalized do a lot of speed enforcement
at various different places when we get
you know identified as an issue um we've
done specific enforcement recently in
the High Street at molden which resulted
in um 54 positive speed checks for uh in
excess of the 20 mph limit and we've
also done once Road as well um but I
mention those ones specifically because
they're within you know probably earshot
of here but but also on there you'll see
that we've done it um throughout the
wider District as well um and we will
continue to do that and we'll continue
to work with our partners at the council
and the community speedwatch in order to
to complete those
duties uh and then we get on to our
rural engagement team so we're really
really fortunate in Moren that um we
have some fantastic support by the rural
engagement team you you you might
regularly get them referred to or heard
referred to as the r team from Essex
police now they're um part of our local
policing support unit with an Essex
police that work out of um um
headquarters and
Borum and they provide support
specifically around rural crime and the
type of issues that there are in in
relation to rural crime in our more
rural parts of of Essex and in molden we
are one of their um their priority
districts so we do get quite a good
service from them as a as a as a
district um so they do some fantastic
work um in relation to hair coursing um
un um unauthorized encampments and what
we are seeing a little bit more of now
more recently um in this part of ess6
off-road vehicles in the rural areas um
it's something that used to um be the
bane of my professional life in my
previous district and the the west of
the county um but now um we are starting
to see a little bit more of that up here
um certainly getting reports through
from members of the community and
elected members in regards to that so
that's something that we also get
support from them around as well um
which is very POS positive um and then a
little bit further there in relation to
hair cing so op Galileo as um Spencer
alluded to um it's both a proactive and
reactive um operation and I use that by
ter in the terminology ways we don't
just respond to incidents as they're
being reported to us of course we do
that but we try to predict where they're
going to be and also who it is as well
so that we can prevent it from happening
in the first place and then ensure that
we when we need to can take enforcement
action um so you'll see there in the 12
months to March 2023 180 incidents were
reported in relation to hair csing which
was compared to 363 for the previous 12
months which was just over a
50% reduction in relation to the reports
of hair cing and that's from the strong
approach being taken by the rec team as
well as local offices as well as part of
op Galileo so that's continuing and I
was at a meeting recently um I forget
the name I have so many um but you know
but op Galileo and hair coring and the
red team are committed to continuing
their work in in Moren as I say and
Moren along with braan Alford and I
think one other I forget now at this
time of the evening but um it was we
definitely one of the priority districts
for the red team so that's always
positive and that chair is my my
presentation thank you very much Chief
Inspector balard so members um I'm sure
some of you have got some questions um
that you'd like to
present councilor Moy thank you ch um
yeah I must
say from the farming Community we have
noticed reduction in hair
cing and and the people that go with it
that's the worst thing um but several
farmer friends of mine have noticed that
you with the Land Rover and your the
pickup that you've got that's been a bit
more visual lately I don't whe that's
been a conscious thing but they do that
is rather nice to see that about all all
those Vehicles whether you've got more
now I don't know but in the last year or
so we've definitely noticed patrolling
or cuz I'd imagine they're they're
perfect for shooting across that or
flight was that a conscious thing um
thank you councelor um so yes uh it is a
conscious thing in so much as we try to
appropriately equip our officers in
order to do their job so it would be it
wouldn't be particularly um cost
effective or or appropriate to give them
a for Fiesta to go and try and deal with
hair cing but I think from your
perspective you are right they have had
some new kit they have um as they should
because they do a fantastic job and um
and I think they'd worn out their old
kit to be fair so I think it was only
right and proper that um Essex police um
supported them in that way um in regards
to the increased visibility I don't
necessarily think they've been given
more I think they are just trying to be
more visible where they've where they've
been so successful um in relation to
some of the things that they've dealt
with in the in the past they're now
afforded the opportunity to be less
reactive and more proactive you know if
air Crossing's down by 50% that's 50%
less incidents that are having to attend
to on a on a 12-month basis so that time
they've spent or would have been spent
going to those incidents they could be
more visible in the more visible in the
community and I think that's always got
to be our um our goal not just for the
Royal Engagement team but in general you
know that first pillar for us is that
prevent if we can prevent then we've got
less work to do and less people are
victims of crime and everyone is happy
in that regard so I think that's that
that's the key thing around there
so
absolutely okay any other members got
any questions at
all it won't surprise you to know I've
got some
[Laughter]
questions um so um I was going to ask
you just a couple of questions um an
update really with regard to and and
forgive me if I've forgotten some of the
detail of this from the last meeting I
hope I haven't but the mon District
Council Office hub and how it's working
do you have an interview room there now
do you have that facility now because I
know that was something that there was a
little bit of a question mark over
before and also do you get a lot of
people come in to the desk and actually
talk to your officers there or is it
more just from phone calls or just just
an understanding of how that works
should be helpful thank you thank you
chair um so in answer to your first
question we don't currently have a an
interview room as per what we would
require under the police and criminal
Evidence Act um however Spencer has been
working very hard I I can't take any
credit for this at all Spencer's done
all the work along with Richard and and
others at the council so there are plans
for um additional area within the
council for police and partner use it
won't just be for us it will be a
community Hub yes similar to other hubs
um in other Council buildings in Essex
and I think unless I'm going to have to
duck I think there is um plans for that
to include those sort of facilities as
well for all to use and it wouldn't be
just for officers it would be for for
Council um officers as well um in
relation to um the front office um yes
we do get people come in and they do
come in to talk to us um um we don't get
as many as you would at one of the
largest stations like South End and
baswan and chelsford but um we certainly
have enough to require a um two
full-time service desk assistants that
work out of here and and Alternate the
days
um and we certainly have people come in
to speak to officers and they use the
yep phone so yeah no definitely do I
think it's it's good to have an
understanding of that I mean the other
question that I've got which I think you
you almost invited there was um around
the theft offenses being up so much by
41.8% so um for the benefit of everybody
here how does that relate to other data
in essics across essics and also you
said you'd explain a little bit more
about the type of offenses they were and
also do you think that that's due to the
cost of Liv living C pris that was the
other question not a problem thank you
chair um I tried to be balanced I
couldn't just tell you all the good news
you know we have to we have to talk
about some of the stuff that we need to
improve on um so so basically theft so
theft we break it down into various
different um uh classifications from a
police perspective around recorded crime
so you've got theft from a person um
theft of a pedal cycle um shoplifting or
other theft so from uh from a mod
District council's perspect mod
District's perspective um we are down on
all about the shoplifting and the other
theft so shoplifting is as described um
but the other theft would be any other
type of theft that doesn't relate to
either a shoplifting or a theft from a
person okay so it's a bit of a Catal so
it is other theft is generally going to
be one of the larger recorded crimes
because it it catches a lot of different
classification types of offense um how
we compared to the rest of Essex um I
would say we are on par as an average um
I don't think we're a particular outlier
and we are seeing as a force those
offenses increasing across the board
have you seen increases like that in
other areas you have yes okay um but
just to put it into some context um and
and I I referenced my colleague to the
left um mden some of the percentages
with M can sometimes be a little bit
challenging because of the low volumes
um and M than is the lowest recorded
crime if you take Stan at airport out of
um the is the load lowest recorded crime
area in Essex from a police perspective
um so when I say that that shoplifting
has increased um by that percentage I'm
talking 57 offenses over the course of a
calendar year okay so we aren't talking
huge numbers but it is still going up
and and also you know I'll talk more
broadly than just m um in general terms
I do think that obviously there's always
going to be like there was with domestic
violence when during the covid pandemic
and other things there's always going to
be an impact and an effect effect on
crime figures based on the socio the
socio economic figures you know
situation of the time yeah no thank you
very much and thank you for that report
which was great we don't have a
recommendation for that as it was a
verbal report but thank you very much
for your time and I think we all found
that very informative I certainly did so
moving on to our next item um we have a
performance report on the function of
the South ethics parking partnership in
the modern District which was quite a
mouthful um
um we have again this is a verbal report
and I'm pleased to Welcome to our
meeting tonight Nick binder of the south
ess6 parking partnership SE who will
present the report tonight thank you Mr
binder yeah thank you chair Spencer's
just going to set me challenging my
eyes I left the Spencers I couldn't see
it from
here the glasses on uh yeah thank you
for inviting me uh here tonight to give
me an opportunity to talk about the s
fic parking partnership i' just like to
give you a bit of an overview of how the
parking Partnerships are established uh
our roles and responsibilities some of
the challenges we face and some of the
initiatives that we we have in place um
so when we talk in terms of parking
enforcement you you may hear there's two
references there's what we call on
street parking enforcement and off
street parking enforcement and they
they're two different responsibilities
in terms of who the enforcement
Authority is so terms of the on Street
that's your public Highway and that's a
responsibility of Essex County Council
who the highway Authority and you may
also had that heard that referred to as
what they call civil parking enforcement
and then there's off street parking and
off street parking enforcement which is
responsibility of all the individual D
sorry districts and Burrows and city
council uh within those areas uh and
each of those um councils are the
enforcement Authority in their own right
so uh so our responsibility is through
SE which is the sou etics parking
partnership is the on street parking
function um there was actually two new
parking Partnerships were introduced in
2011 uh by ess6 County Council uh
because at the time they were running
their operation at a £900,000
deficit so clearly they needed to
operate that in a different uh more
efficient manner uh so the two parking
Partnerships were form so there is
actually a North Essex parking
partnership and a South parking
partnership so South essics is
responsible for bason brenwood Castle
Point Rochford chelsford and yourselves
and as you can see they got ord's brain
Tre Colchester tendering eping FR and
harow is responsibility of North Essex
parking partnership so Essex County
Council has delegated that function to
the parking Partnerships and those local
authorities via what they call a joint
committee agreement um so we run that
that first term for 11 years um we
signed a new agreement on the 30th of
June 2022 so that will be for another
5-year term with the option to extend uh
annually to a maximum of eight years so
ultimately it say it's County council's
function but they've given it to the
local authorities under a partnership
umbrella to deliver it on their behalf
and they've delegated that whole
function to us to to
operate so in terms of our
responsibilities under that joint
committee agreement so the enforcement
of the public Highway parking
restrictions across those six sou6
parking partnership areas uh we
currently have 35 civil enforcement
officers that operate across those six
areas uh we have officers that are based
within each uh of the local authorities
uh so we have two offices based in
molden uh which are within the sort of
partnership Hub area with the community
safety
officers um
um but although although we say we have
two offices based in molden we actually
have the flexibility to move those staff
around any of those areas so we have
quite a lot of resilience so if there's
ever sickness or holidays or or or
shortness of Staff in any area we can
deploy the staff anywhere if we feel
like an area needs assistant with
particular parking problems and needs a
bit more sustained enforcement we have
that facility so we we do work as a
partnership we're not working in
individual are silos with in that
parking partnership we've got that
flexibility to move our resource
accordingly uh in addition to that we've
got some really good working
arrangements with the community safety
officers particularly in molden and uh
in brenwood uh whereby we actually pay
the councils for the services of those
officers and we Empower them and give
them the training to be able to issue
penalty charge notices on our behalf uh
and that's worked out really well
particularly in the night time economy
whereas our contracted staff they can't
be there at all hours of the day but a
lot of these officers have already
contracted to be working with in those
areas so particularly molden they do a
lot of work in the High Street and the
residential sort of parking zones on our
behalf and they can do that during the
day and in the evenings and that's been
a really good example of the sort of
partnership working um that we do um we
also do the administration of all the
residents parking schemes and the on
Street pay and display uh schemes you
don't have any on Street pan display in
molden but we we obviously do the the
residence parking schemes that you have
uh another area that we are responsible
for is the maintenance of parking
related signs and lines and that's only
parking related signs and lines so if
it's a yellow line a residance parking
scheme limited waiting a parking Bay
that's our responsibility all your other
markings like the giveaways and the
white lines Etc that remains with Essex
County Council and that's that's their
responsibility so if you see any faded
yellow lines you can come to US Direct
and that's our responsibility we've got
local contractors that we use that can
come out and and carry those works out
for us uh and another big piece of work
that we do is we consider applications
for new parking restrictions so anyone
can send an application into us we've
got an online application form so if a
member of public uh decides that they
feel that they might need yellow lines
or they have particular parking issue
they can apply to us we will consider
every applicational Merit uh we will do
an assessment of those areas so that
will include you know various site
visits to establish is there a parking
problem does it warrant a parking
restriction we also assess that against
an implementation policy so we've
obviously got higher priority down to
low priority uh and then we will make an
assessment of that and then we will U
liaz uh with the Joint Committee Member
for each of those respective areas and
the lead officer and when make a
decision on whether a scheme can go
ahead or not so um I'm sure you have
members of the public come to you and
say how do I get yellow lines well just
send them towards us and then we will
take the work on from there and and give
them a rationale decision around that um
just to give you a bit of an overview of
how the governance works so it's
actually a stand alone account so it's
it's an account that is a responsibility
of the joint committee so they determine
how that account is run if there's any
surplus or any deficit it's for the
joint committee to decide how that's
managed so it doesn't form in any part
of the general accounts for each of the
six areas so it's almost a standalone
well it is a standalone business model
so the set committee consists of a
nominated member from each of the
partnership areas so councelor Simon
Morgan is your Joint Committee Member
for molden uh that's also supported by a
lead officer so it's Nicholas cider for
uh molden and again that link in nicely
CU she's part of that Community safety
team so we all work very closely in
establishing you know if there's any
issues any problems so if there's a
particular parking problem that is
causing concern uh you know either
approach Nicha or approach myself and
then we can work out how we can best uh
best manage that um any any monies that
or surpluses that we make within the
parking partnership and the last couple
of years that's getting more difficult
to establish with all the cost of living
Etc uh that's Ring fenced in legislation
so we can only um spend that on car park
improvements or parking improvements and
and and and Highway um measures um and
because sep is not a IL legal entity in
its own right um Champ City Council the
lead Authority for sep so Cher will
deliver the function on their behalf so
chancer can engage in all the contracts
and the various bits and pieces we need
to be able to to operate that for them
so all the staff are employed by Champ
City Council including myself but we
work for the parking partnership so
although uh I'm called the south parking
partnership manager I'm effectively all
your managers so any of those areas if
you got particular problems around
parking you can come direct to me might
regret saying that but and and obviously
I can give you the the the advice at
that time on what we can what we can't
do what our responsibilities are what we
legally we can and legally we can't do
and that's probably uh or and I find
that's probably the best route to come
and then we can advise you accordingly
uh we've got some uh traffic regulation
order technicians that work with us that
go out and do all the the the
assessments on this the signs and and
and parking issues so again they're a
source of of good information so any
advice you need then that's that's the
place to
come so I I will'll give you just an
over because we did talk about the
importance of it being a a single
operating model so it's quite important
that we we run it at break even and and
have enough Surplus to be a to invest
back into the various functions that we
deliver uh because clearly if we if we
don't make that Surplus and go into a
large deficit position it comes to the
default of the the partner U authorities
to to to address that uh so been very
successful since we implemented the
parking partnership we we've always made
a surplus uh year on uh so just to give
you an example of the outturn for last
year um we've got two distinct parts of
the operation we call it the enforcement
operation and the trro operation so the
enforcement operation is what brings the
income into the parking partnership and
our only income streams are penalty
charge notices uh resident parking
permits and on Street pan display play
and then we've got the TR function which
is a cost of the parking partnership so
that's all the technicians that go out
and put in all the uh new parking
schemes and all our maintenance of signs
and lines so we managed to cover all
those costs through the parking
partnership um and as you can see taking
into account those costs we still had a
surplus on top of that of
129,000 uh and then that will go back
into the investment back invest back
into the function it sort of acts as our
Capital fund there's obviously lots of
replacement of vehicles and pan display
machines and all those types of bits and
pieces that goes uh I think the other
important thing that's that's been quite
successful is we've been able to
maintain a £400,000 reserve in the
parking partnership that used to be
200,000 but covid sort of you know hit
everybody quite hard uh we managed to
ride through that okay with the
surpluses we had but we've increased
that Surplus for now to 400,000 000 so
if there is any downturn in the accounts
then we can have that to fall back on so
in terms of of molden and and the reason
I put molden on here because it's it's
probably a good example in that if you
rely on just PCN income it's very
difficult to make the function pay for
itself but we acknowledge that some of
our partner authorities don't have the
opportunities like chelsford and
brenwood where we've got sort of high
streets with lots of on Street pants
display around the high streets and
that's where we make that extra Surplus
um apparently charge notice
unfortunately the level of charges set
by central government so we have no
control over that and those charges have
been the same since
2008 so 65% of our income is through
penly charge notices but whereas our
costs from 2011 have continued to rise
each year the parently charge notice
line stays the same so we've got no way
of offsetting a increased expend against
pen charge notices um and there's a
perception that all you know you can go
down the road there so much money there
you you'll make loads of money with all
these tickets but the reality is is
there's a cost to issue the ticket but
there's also the bigger cost is to
recover it and there's a whole legal
process that the public can go through
to challenge pcns uh and and you know
the profit margin on the p is very
minimal so we do rely on these other
functions across the paring part so the
success of the partnership is that the
areas that have the big income
opportunities we can share that across
it's one account and then we can
distribute that across the other area so
uh molden we've always run it at sort of
like cost neutral but this is just an
example of you know with the increased
in salaries which has been very good for
staff and the the extra costs we're
starting to find that some of the areas
we are starting to go into deficit we
will be looking at how we can improve
that uh but that's not unsurprising that
that that's what's expected from from
those areas
is um so talking about investment uh
just to give you some of the the the
things that we have done a big part of
our cost is replacement of on Street P
display machines uh enforcement handh
computers keeping up with technology it
moves so quick these days but the the
the technology is getting faster and
swifter so we like to keep up with that
and we give our staff the best equipment
so they got the best opportunity to to
work as quickly as they can uh with look
after the staff from a welfare point of
view so we've invested quite a lot in in
body cameras which has been very good
um the the new digital Tero system not
the mo most exciting cell to 10 one
outside of parking but that was a really
important piece of work in that we had a
company that went out and remeasured all
the signs and the restrictions within
the whole of Essex because there was a
lot of discrepancies between that and
the legal order and it really to make
all the legal orders 100% compl compant
um and that obviously increases our our
income through being able to reinforce
all the the um the signs and lines uh
and I suppose one of the most important
one there is O over the period of the
parking partnership each of the partners
has had an equal share of quite a
significant sum of money uh so molden
along with Champs the other partners
have all had 302,000
714 given to the partners to invest as
part of section 55 the ACT which is into
car park improvements and and highways
and I think most of the areas have have
spent that money on their own pound
display stocks and that in their off
street car park so that's been very
successful from that
aspect so to give you some sort of data
around what we
do um I do produce an annual report
every year uh and your Joint Committee
Member will have access to that and it's
always published on our website and that
will provide a whole host of data and
Patrol data and financial data uh so if
anyone's interested that is that is
there but this is just a bit of a
snapshot from that report um and you can
see there's various contraventions and
and contravention codes and where we've
issued the PCN so most of those pcns
will be on what we call restricted
streets which is the single yellow and
double yellow lines and the residents
parking areas is is is tends to be the
the the most activity in those areas
so you can see over the last Financial
year there's
1,704 pcns issued in molden of which the
visits the streets there was 16 sorry
17,6
63 but I think one of the key things
here is that number we say observations
so I suppose this is really gives an
overview of how difficult it can be to
issue a PCN because dependent on the
contention code and the type of
restriction aot lot of these
restrictions have what we call an
observation period so we have to
determine because they do allow people
to load and unload so if it's a double
yellow line without a loading ban on it
a vehicle can park on there and load and
unload and if they're seem to be doing
that then they're allowed to do that um
so those observations are where we're
seeing the or potential contentions
they've either driven off before we've
issued the PCN so we're in the process
of issuing it or we're doing an
observation period and establish that we
actually you loading unloading and
that's probably some of the the issues
around the High Street parking and the
type of restrictions you have um it does
allow that loading and unloading and we
have to recognize that and and allow
that to persist I think in in terms of
your High Street which is probably
slightly different to a lot of the other
high streets we have is is the shops
that that sort of serve the High Street
they don't have the service areas Beyond
it and if you look at the Champs and the
brentwoods beyond the shops are
designated loading areas so they can
make the restrictions harsher in in the
street but you need to be able to serve
these businesses and it's getting that
balance right and so that's that's a
difficult
difficulty um so I think I think from
those stats we're out there we're doing
a lot of patrols and we're doing a lot
of observations but you know from PCM
wise it's it's not every single car
that's that's going to have those
pcns um so I spoke about the molden
community Safety Office so part of those
figures uh they do an amount of work for
us so they've issued 235 ptns
2,182 uh visits to streets and again you
know 1,96 observations so you know you
see these vehicles you can observe and
there there's an issue but we they need
to be given the the due opportunity to
uh have that observation period so I
just picked out modern High Street cuz
in any area your High Street is probably
where most of our activity happens so
again just some figures so 272 pcns
issued the patrol to that street was
2,147 times and that
1,445 observations so
um there a few figures there so if I can
move on to a few operational challenges
and I think
that's our favorite so there's two
really there's the school parking and
there's the foot footway parking so
really I've given three examples here
and and I suppose this is really to
demonstrate is that I suppose from a uh
a memb of the public point of view this
is this is to say what we can and what
we can't do and what we legally can do
and I suppose some of the discrepancies
where the public uh sort of you know
can't understand well why can't can't
you issue that PC into that particular
vehicle so if you look at um a for
example now one of the contravention
codes we don't have is is obstruction so
obstruction does stay with our police
colleagues um so if a car's obstructing
then that's not a PCN contention for us
but in terms of parking restrictions if
there's a parking restriction on the
road it goes from the center of the road
to the nearest private building line so
if you've got a yellow line on a road or
a double yellow line and a car's parked
on the pavement that's part of the
public Highway and the yellow line is
included within that restriction so what
we're issuing the PCN for is the
contravention of the yellow line not the
fact it's parked on a pavement and it's
obstructing so in in example a for for
example that's a single yellow line and
they have a Time plate with them so it's
not throughout the whole day so that
could be Monday to Saturday between the
hours of 8 and 6 so when the car's
parked with its wheels up within that
time period our guys can issue a PCN
because it's contren in the yellow line
outside of those times that car can park
there again our guys have to walk by it
so from a member of the public point of
view it's like this is madness but
that's the legislation that that we're
there and and again that then could be
considered an obstruction and that's
really for the police to determine
whether that warrants an obstruction or
not um likewise with B there's no
restriction on the road so we have no
legal powers to issue a PCN to that car
and then if you look at C which is
completely parked on the pavement it's
the double yellow line also includes the
pavement so we can issue a PCN for that
vehicle so it's a Minefield of ambiguity
I think is is the words to say and I
think the other thing to to point out as
well is that people Park on Pavements
they tend to do it very quick quickly
this what we call a short short-term
invas invasive Parker where they quickly
pop up to nip in somewhere to come out
so although we have a reporting system
so we've got an online reporting system
that the public can ring us and say or
or or fill out an online form to say
there's a contention nine times out of
10 by the time we got there that's gone
and that's exactly the same issue for
the for the police and I think from a
police perspective an obstruction that's
stopping traffic getting through and
it's been there all day and it's
complete problem then they have the
necessary powers to move the vehicles
and do that but I suppose from parking
on Pavements it's not all day every day
it's it's it's we're talking minutes and
that's that's the challenge so just in
terms of that within London we have
slightly different legislation under the
traffic management act in that there is
a blanket ban on pavement parking in
London so there has been a consultation
by central government which was in
August
2020 who reached out out to the local
authorities outside of London uh to get
our views on on pavement parking so the
general view was that authorities wanted
to take that on uh there's various
methods that can happen there uh one of
the areas they looking out is that it
could be a shared responsibility in that
they could decriminalize the obstruction
element of that but I think that comes
with challenges or they could do a bland
on a pavement parking now the problem
with that is there are areas and I'll
use CH as an example we've actually got
residents parking schemes with part of
the Bays marked on the pavement so if
it's a blanket ban you then have to do
the reverse and mark the areas where you
allow people to park so that can become
a bit H but the the end line is is
government are looking at that and it
will take away that ambiguity in that we
will be able to do the pavement parking
regardless the last we heard uh from my
colleague Richard who's in the North and
he's part of the British Parking
Association is that the Secretary of
State for roads and local transport me
recently mentioned a speech that the
government response to the
consultation including their options for
change was a matter of months away so
what months away means I don't know but
we're hoping uh we're all sitting
waiting to see what the outcome is and I
think it will just clarify a lot better
and we'll have a lot more powers to be
to deal with that moving forward
so our other one is the is the school
parking this isn't a SE issue this is a
national issue um the problem we have is
res resource uh if I could have a person
standing outside every school had a
parking restriction every morning and
every afternoon we probably go a long
way to solving the problem but it's not
financially sustainable so we we have to
try and Achieve that with the staff
resource we have uh we can do that by
having what we call a regular school
rotor so we're rotating around the
schools I think as I mentioned earlier
if there's a particular problem outside
of school where it's becoming
unsustainable you know you can even talk
to your Nicola your lead officer come to
me direct and we do do a lot of
partnership working with Community
safety officers and police within all
the areas to do action days um and and
that that works but again as soon as you
move away from that it's the habits can
very quickly come back in place I think
we also get a lot of demand particularly
from residentials residential areas
around school parking wanting parking
restrictions uh our policy is we will
allow parking where we feel it's safe to
do so so we're not in the habit of just
clearing roads at certain times of the
day there's either a safety issue
throughout the day it can't just be at
school times uh so we do try and
encourage where it's safe to do so that
we we will allow that and that's part of
our implementation but we've also
learned from from history is that
putting parking restrictions all around
schools doesn't necessarily solve the
problem it just pushes it further along
the road or into the next area and you
very quickly find residents within those
areas are completely mythed as I didn't
buy a house by the school but now you've
pushed the parking problem to me and we
have to respect that sort of view as
well so we we looked at it a few years
back and said a lot of this is more
around education getting to work with
the schools the schools have got access
to all the parents they can do this
through newsletters Etc so we set up a
an initiative called the school parking
initiative um I've just put on the side
there the schools in molden that have
taken on this initiative we have a
designated resource called Jack sharp
who constantly contacts all the schools
so we've contacted every school in Essex
and reached out to them and this really
is an educational thing where we get the
children involved we get the schools
involved uh it's called free PR is
called the character and it's around
care caution and
consideration um and throughout that
initiative we're kind of getting the
schools to do a bit of the work and
instead of putting restrictions down we
create what we call fre PR zones and
this is um all around encouraging
children to not park within those zones
but if you walk in or you go on a bike
or you want one of their little scooters
there will be the children who act as
3pr patrols so they they've got all the
the uniform and the children get a token
as they walk through that checkpoint and
then the token goes into a Class part
and then there's various uh prizes for
the winner of the month uh for the
winner of the year so we've invested
some of the money into schools that are
really engaging in this and really
driving it Forward we've bought them
little scooter bike park things a cycle
Park uh I don't know what you call them
that go into the school uh and I suppose
the benefit is the parking partnership
pay for with so all the promotional
materials uniforms the banners Etc
that's paid for by us because we want
the schools to take this up you know the
first thing if you're go into a school
we've all got budget pressures how much
is it going to cost me well nothing um
but it does rely on schools engaging
with us so some are very engaging
embrace it others don't feel that it's
perhaps a problem uh and we deliver
certain types of package so there's a
gold package silver and bronze the gold
package is the is the ultimate one um
and by by once schools engage with us
then obviously you know we're happy to
go there and give them a lot more of our
resource to try and you know if they
need the enforcement after this then you
know we we follow that up um and we get
engaged with lots of things like Park
and stride so uh I think this one was in
Rochford particularly um and it's just
working with other local Authority
bodies or local businesses we've worked
with as we've worked with lots of
supermarkets that if they're near
schools and they allow the parents in to
to park and then you know we give them
the designated route to walk into the
school which enables them to walk into
the zone to get their token to go into
the school um and we found It's very
effective if the schools keep driving it
and we keep driving it with the schools
it's but it can easily just drift into
the background so it's it's a constant
um uh involvement of that and then
there's a few more bits and pieces is
just to sort of uh you can see we've got
a character uh we get some volunteers
sometimes to dress up in the suit and uh
go out to the schools we do assemblies
so our view is it's it's aimed at
primary schools and we're hoping that
you know the children we teaching we're
probably not going to change the adults
that come to the school in the car but
this might make children think or the
parents think as they go on to secondary
school and as they leave school it's
just around education and we're finding
that's just as effective as as may be
you know us putting a yellow line
outside of school and saying nothing and
walking away from it and can't guarantee
that we get a guy there every day to to
to manage it um and that's the end of my
presentation thank you thank you very
much Mr bines that's really appreciated
um I'm going to come to members to to
ask um any questions they have or any
comments I mean one thing I will say
straight away is that I think as members
and I don't know if other members here
agree one of the biggest things you have
from your residents are all the issues
around the things you've described both
for the new members that we have and for
older ones I think to um to have that um
information tonight is quite useful so
members do you have any um questions oh
we've got loads that's good I I'll I'll
start I'll start off with uh councelor
Haywood there oh one's going to be
yellow lines obviously it's always going
to be yellow lines um I'm at mland so
obviously I know where the smaller
Villages you're saying about the um
having a list of obviously how many pcns
you've given out in mm what's it like in
The Villages have you do you have a a
statistics of how many how many you come
out and get in the smaller Villages cuz
we very rarely see people we've got
yellow lines we've got a lot in our
village we got a lot of bad parking but
we don't tend to have we've had one
parking parking Warden down once this
year I think three times over the course
of a week and that's all we've seen this
year so um we've got yellow lines but
they're not doing the job so is there a
list you've got to say what tickets
you've given in the smaller Villages so
we get an idea of how you know if you
are patrolling our smaller Villages not
just mine but all of us in smaller
villes are you patrolling us as well or
you just aiming at the larger
towns that makes
sense oh that's a very good question um
yes I can I can get stats per road on
the system we've got we've got a very
good reporting system and it can sort of
tell me the number of patrols pcns
issued observations you know that so
that can be condensed right down per
Road um I think the reality is is that
you know the smaller villages will get
less enforcement coverage than perhaps
the High Street the in molden because
there is a constant stream of traffic
and there's more there's more potential
issues for us not being there with buses
not being able to get through so we will
look at the the network and what it
serves and and the importance of us
being there um I suppose the the good
piece of work working in partnership
with the community safety officers is is
that's the part of the work we said
because they do lots of work themselves
in and out around these areas and that
while you're there can you have a look
at the the yellow lines and etc for us
so um I haven't got the stats with me
right now but I won't sit here and say
yes you get someone there every day of
the week but equally if there's a
particular problem that's building up
because I think we do rely on having to
move our resource around and hit areas
and then leave this area while we're
here cuz cuz while I'm there it's not
happening here and vice versa but we can
bring staff over from from champ for
example uh but again we're pulling them
from an area but yeah we're happy to do
that and I think that's where you can
feed that through nickola or come to US
Direct and we can see if we can improve
that for you and and give our view on it
as
well quickly come back if that's all
right just just ack obviously yes we do
have like School problems we have a
restriction and everyone parks on the
airlines we've got a bus cage every
parks on that and it causes us a major
problem at the doctors they park inside
the double yellow lines but I I think we
need like most of our small village even
if we had once or twice a year someone
must come out our way and some people
got a few tickets then obviously it will
stop it happening as much you know you
need to do it once or twice and it would
help us definitely thank you councelor
Neil did you have a question it was c i
it was so fast that I could councelor
Sizzle Norman thank you
councelor SZ Norman thank you hello um I
have two questions the first one is I
live in Burnham on Crouch I'm a a town
counselor as well as a district
counselor um do you know Burnham do you
realize that we have a a bridge coming
into out there's only one way into
Burham that's over a
bridge now as you come over the bridge
at the bottom of that bridge just about
well 50 well not 30 yards on there's a
Crossing now this Crossing is outside
the post office now I have personally
nearly got um knocked over many many
times on that Crossing because of the
fact that it's coming over the bridge
now if there's yellow lines right the
the way down on the left hand side on
the side that you're
driving s in the last three or four
years we have had several new shops just
further on on the same
side there's no parking outside they've
got yellow
lines we find that they're having to
park in places that have got yellow
lines we very rarely see anybody um come
and enforce
it um what I'm concerned about and this
is probably a council thing as well
planning that the shops obviously need
people to come in the shops and they
need to somewhere for their customers to
to
park well the road opposite the the
shops is the only Road where there isn't
any yellow lines
so therefore that
road gets all the parking for all that
area and when the traffic's coming down
over the bridge we have all this
problem how do we deal with that I mean
it is a big problem because it's going
to be an accident there
very at any time because there are
people trying to cross the road to get
to the shops there's yellow
lines and they can't come now what do
you deal with situations like that or
how do we deal with itk thank you
counselor thank you yeah in in terms of
the yellow lines that's something our
Enforcement Officers can can deal with
again I suppose when we're there if we
had a man on that yellow line all the
time probably less likely people would
park on there I think if if I understand
the question correctly is is it the fact
that the other side of the road is
unrestricted and vehicles are parking
there that is causing an issue with
passing of
vehicles um what what's the actual name
of the road because this it sounds
familiar right you come over the bridge
into bur way and just just past that
there's a Crossing where I've nearly got
over several times
because if people are used the town they
don't know I know they're supposed to at
the they don't know it's going to be a
crossing almost at the end of at the
bottom of the bridge and now it's got
worse because of all these new
businesses that are
now on that side of the r yeah I I I
probably think the best thing
is uh we mentioned about the application
process if if if you can fill out or
somebody can fill out an application
form just setting out what the problems
are and the challenges what's there at
the moment what's not and if there's a
solution that anyone feels might Rectify
that then our technicians can go out and
have a look at that but we can only
comment on the parking aspect of it so
if it's around is the is the Crossing in
the right place or not that's an Essex
County council issue and speed and all
those types of things fall back to Essex
County Council but we can we can look at
it and give it an assessment over from a
parking perspective and whether it's fit
for purpose what's there at the moment
so really you got to go somebody else
rather than yourself can can I sorry
sorry if I can just interrupt you there
counselor sorry so um in terms of a link
for um people to be able to apply if we
could provide that through the committee
Clark that would be good I can do that
um so just very quickly is the advice
that that's what um The Counselor should
should do from fromont yellow line's all
putting a new parking restriction in
that's we've got the the thy to do that
right but if it ties in
with other Highway things such
as speed orines then that be more County
counil give you an assessment from
a thank you thank you very much can I
just ask one more question sorry be a
quick one if a car is parked with a
cover on it in the road um permanently
in a place it should be not on a parking
is that allowed for months on
end uh if if if there's not a parking
restriction there then obviously it's
not in contravention of any P charges
noce his weaken issue uh I think I can
only obviously working in chelsford we
could if it could be determined that it
was an abandoned vehicle and then it's
not taxed and insured and and it's it's
on the highway then uh spencon knows
this better than me but there is there
is legislation around abandoned vehicles
within the environmental
Department um but if it's taxed insured
it can legally park on on the road thank
you thank you I'll move on to councelor
Neil now because I'm just wary of the
time so thank you I think got a very
quick question um it's really when when
you're coming out to do patrols and and
and that kind of thing especially when
it comes to schools do you ever actually
give the school's warnings that you're
going to be turning up um at any time
because
interestingly um we have a big issue
from where I am of people parking
opposite the school causing absolute
Havoc um we offer them the Village Hall
car park free of charge to go and park
and and literally walk around two
corners to get to the school um but this
evening I've suddenly received a text
message to say please don't park
opposite the school um so I'm predicting
you're going to have someone at the
school tomorrow it might be just my
cynical
nature but we only get told as parents
not to park there and magically it seems
that the enforcement guys are there the
next day so do you ever warn schools or
that you're going to be
around uh there's a mole in the camp
no
um from I suppose from Air officer's
point of view no we don't we don't warn
schools we're coming we just will turn
up on a road to and and go there
obviously we we use Community safety
officers as well and I don't know if
they're engaging with schools in other
aspects and they might happen to say oh
we're in the area tomorrow and someone's
given the heads up I I don't know but no
we don't we're very random we're ad hoc
we don't let people know we're coming so
that's the general rule but yeah it's
it's obviously uh found its way around
somehow thank you um and were there any
other questions from anybody did you
have one councelor Moy did you no you
didn't okay well that's good well I'm
not going to ask anymore now because I'm
very mindful of the time and everyone's
questions have have answered mine so
that's fantastic so thank you very much
for that Mr
binder um so with that members um I have
no other um urgent items of business and
so I am going to close the meeting at I
can just about see the clock 8:19 no
9:19 p.m. and thank you very much
members so the meeting is closed um as